one cabinet minister is considered
unfortunate to lose three within six
months presents a challenge for the UK's
prime minister Rishi sunak
amid a swirl of accusations of bullying
and intimidation tactics is the latest
exit from government Deputy Prime
Minister Dominic Raab who was also the
Justice Minister and a staunch supporter
of sunac from the get-go in his
leadership bid but a five-month-long
investigation into allegations of Rob
overseeing a hostile work culture
revealed two counts of misconduct had
been upheld and as he said he would Rob
stood down
in his resignation letter he pledged his
continued support for the Prime Minister
but defended his conduct and called the
inquiry flawed and one that set a
dangerous precedent that would encourage
spurious complaints against ministers
opposition politicians disagree
I don't know why Dominic Robb in the
middle of a cost of living crisis
thinks that anybody wants to hear about
his whining about having to resign what
I think everybody wants is strong
leadership and that has been palpably
absent here reports of his behavior
surfaced back in 2021 when Rob served
under Boris Johnson and while he was
foreign secretary when he delayed
returning home from holiday during the
chaotic withdrawal of UK Embassy
Personnel from Afghanistan
but the man who once stepped in to lead
the country when Johnson was
hospitalized with covid-19 remained at
the heart of government
the Dominic Robb now gone the Prime
Minister now finds himself without his
most vocal political Ally and there are
still questions of why it took so long
for Mr sunac to address the issue of Mr
Robb's conduct and if he had been warned
before hiring him as his deputy
the loss of the prime minister's Chief
Ally comes at a particularly difficult
time for sunac months of strikes soaring
inflation and energy prices have tested
the resolve of the country and its
leaders after the high drama of the
Johnson years and Liz truss is short but
turbulent tenure as leader sunac
promised accountability integrity and
professionalism a claim he hoped would
convince the public in spite of
questions that remain about the culture
inside Westminster Sonny Gallego Al
Jazeera London